- [Interviewer] So you watched your,
the first video we did together?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What were
your thoughts on that?
- I could talk a long time,
but that's because at least
in myself, I saw honesty.
I saw being both good and bad
and things that made me see
myself as others may see me.
Because as individuals, we don't
know how we look to others,
practicing in front of
a mirror or something
does not give you that full effect
that seeing yourself, boom recorded,
and now on their their posterity,
there's things that are
a little embarrassing
and things that are horrifying.
Some that are acceptable
as is everyone's story.
I'm not unique in that aspect
because we all have our
own quirks, variances.
Some are more extreme than others.
Yeah.
And it allowed me to
see just how deep down
that rabbit hole I went
in terms of my choices in fun
time, but it is what it is.
I hate that phrase, but it's reality.
It's my life.
I have to accept it.
Warts and all.
All I can do is now find my best points,
enhance those, issue the
things that even disturbed me
and makes me a better person overall.
It's not a bad thing
that I recorded myself.
It's not a bad thing that I've let you,
I allowed myself to be recorded
and posted and all that.
I'm all right with that.
It's me.
What also shocked me more
than just seeing myself
in the comments section, as
you well know, there's a lot
of idiots out there, but then
there's a lot of good ones.
And dare I say
of the batch that I sampled,
a little couple here
and then scroll down a lot
and then just catch a couple more,
more supportive then I
thought, more realizing,
hey, we're all individuals.
And you're like, let him be, do him.
And I liked that because that's
something that is missing
from those that fear exposing
themselves to others.
Not like a flasher, but more
like this what's inside here.
And if more people are able
to do that and be unafraid,
it's interesting to see how much
of an audience there is of
people to acknowledge it
and not chastise or demean or insult.
I was happy about that.
Sure.
There were plenty
of people's pre sufficient, supposed,
they end up making comments or suggestions
or beliefs about me that
were either ranging from, eh,
could be something all the way to oh wow.
That person is so far off the mark
and yeah, it doesn't matter.
What makes you think of me?
No, I'm still living.
I'm still going to live my
life, but I can do it better.
And that's what that video taught me.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Thanks.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I think the audience at least
on my channel really appreciates honesty.
- That is what I was able to-
- [Interviewer] That's the key
to a lot of what you see on my channel is
when the interviewee is very open
and honest and it makes
themself vulnerable.
That that goes over really well.
Even if you're a man, even if
you were a bad, bad person.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It goes over really well.
Whereas when you come in and
you're protecting yourself
and you're, you're hiding this
and you're hiding that,
that doesn't go over well.
- Yeah.
That shy neat stuff, yeah,
it shows a disingenuous
and just does not allow that person
to put what they want to put out there.
But yeah, there's a lot
of fear in people and-
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Having the opportunity
to do this was like, yeah.
Cliff diving
from someone that might
be even afraid of water.
That's what it was like.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Here I come cabo or wherever
the Daniel cliffs are.
That has a nice little, yeah.
But I'm happy for me that I am able
to still be alive after
the things I have done,
but also to be accepting of myself.
There's so many people that live
in their bubbles of comfort
but always regret not taking
that one step outside of it.
And hey, I'm happy that I, you know,
jumped both feet out years ago.
- [Interviewer] I mean, it's big problem.
I think a lot of people-
- Oh that's your problem,
okay, a problem with him.
But some people like that.
Yeah.
Cause then they have regrets
and if they have their regrets,
then they have the anger and
hate that comes out of it.
I mean, that's why they
say most raging homophobes
are the secret gay guys.
I mean, I've never dealt with them.
Pastor raging like that.
- [Interviewer] I would think
a hundred percent of them are.
- Hey,
I can see that now more so,
because I can easily realize-
- [Interviewer] You're either turn,
like you see a trans woman
and you you express hatred towards her
or you you'd leave a mean
comment on my channel.
It's either because you're turned on by it
and that you're not comfortable with that.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Or you
have this same tendency
and you don't like that.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But somebody like myself,
I just think they're interesting.
I hope they're happy.
- Yeah.
And that's the reason why it
felt even more comfortable
when I saw it after the fact is
that there was these comments
where like this ain't my thing at all.
But you know,
he's not murdering anybody and I haven't,
I won't, as far as I know,
but, and I'm too incompetent
with anything when, with
weapons or anything?
No, I can't imagine.
- [Interviewer] No, but I,
I found your personality
to be so interesting and warm and easy.
You're so easy to talk to and listen to.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And it's
because of your intelligence
and it's also because
of your ability to be
vulnerable and honest.
And it just,
it just became a very
interesting talk you know?
Yes.
You're talking about stuff that-
- I'm talking with a
monologue not a dialogue.
- [Interviewer] (indistinct), for sure.
- I ever thought so.
- [Interviewer] But it's certainly
a controversial subject matter.
But, your speaking style is great.
Your honesty is great.
Your vulnerability made it
really so easy to listen to.
- Yeah.
Thank you again.
And it helped me just, yeah,
like I said, and realize
that what I'm doing ain't
so damn bad, like I said,
everyone's got their own little skeletons
in their closet, whatever it is.
And once you accept yours
then there's no more skeletons,
you know, you can be free
of any constraint and more
people need to be like that.
I'm surprised that that moment
of clarity didn't happen
until really I saw my video
where I'm able to like see, wow, the ugly,
but then the good.
And then the comments, this
was even more supportive
of the fact that I did do it.
Not necessarily of what I do
or what's done to me, but point is that,
yeah, it's me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I think, I think you're
charming and interesting.
And your personality every
time I see you often now,
because you live right down the street-
- Two blocks.
- [Interviewer] Everyone
even says behind your back
how delightful you are to hang out with.
- And that, if I, if
it's a good camera lens
which it looked like it did
in the video that I saw,
but I mean, I'm probably turning 50 shades
of red because I'm just
like embarrassing, blushing
that's the word, you know,
just to hear nice things.
As a good friend of mine back in Detroit,
a coworker turned, you know,
very good friend of mine.
She, she was like, whenever
she would make a comment
or something and I caught it,
like that, she looked at it
and was like, oh, you're
turning red or you're blushing.
And she would laugh at me about that.
And it made me laugh and yeah.
So that's how I feel like I am right now.
I'm not, you know.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever,
what emotion do you deal with most?
Is it depression or anxiety or
anger or anything like that?
You don't seem to have any of them.
- I have all of those in spades.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- I don't project that unless
that person brought it to me.
And when that happens,
hell hath no fury like me
angered by your dumbass.
- [Interviewer] So,
are you in these people
that just kind of puts
on a life of the party face all the time
and even though you
might be very sad behind?
- The tears of a clown.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I have that.
- [Interviewer] A lot of people do that.
- I resembled my father a lot
and he passed away last December.
And when I think about,
what my father, my coworkers
or other adults that were in the room,
like what they would say about my father,
like when somebody called
him at his job and like, oh,
we're looking for the
funny little fat fellow.
So funny little fat
fellow was my nicknames
for my father that, and the
family had because yeah,
he was the person that just was silly
but he was also sincere, helpful,
like trying to do the
right thing for others.
Like Alzheimer's and dementia got awful.
And after my father's kidney transplant,
it triggered that.
It was a slow decline
toward the end of the bail
assist before the transplant.
But then after transplant, he was gone.
He was around living
for 10 years after that.
But he wasn't himself.
It was like a shell of a person.
And as that,
you've seen the last life
that he was familiar with, like,
he would constantly when I
was his primary caregiver,
cause mom was still working.
And so I was with him and keep in mind
this is just after I got discharged
of the hospital after three months
where I had my severe mental
trauma that caused me to
have those same type of symptoms
that my father was having.
And here I am healing myself
but tending to him as he's declining.
And then, yeah,
seeing that decline
and that he may not refer
to the name for him, Dickey,
which is of course for Richard.
And that's what my uncle would call him.
So he would respond to Dicky,
but not necessarily a
picture of her father.
It was like some days
he didn't know who I was
or who my mom was, but, you know,
he would respond a very cheerfully.
And that's what I'm trying to do here
because this is something
I've never said before.
And it hurts.
It's just, as my father was regressing,
he was like thinking he
was back in high school.
We had to get a double lock,
a double, we, you know,
you have to key to open the
door to get out of the house.
We had to put that on the front door
because he loved to go out
and wander and look for people
In the apartment complex, duplex complex,
apartment building, looking
for people to help them
with their groceries,
his first job was a bag
boy at a you know, market.
And so he'd go around looking for people
that had bags with him
so he can help them.
Cause that's what he
knew, what his job was
but that was, you know, 50 years prior.
Seeing that regression,
seeing that was painful.
And after two, two and a half years
of being that caregiver for
him and finding some resources
through charitable agencies
and nonprofits and other things
to at least help alleviate
the burden from myself
and from my mother when she
was after work or whatever.
And I found some wonderful things
that they used years after I moved out,
but I had to for my own sanity.
And if that's hereditary,
you know, I mean,
I'm not a diabetic like my
father was, knock on wood.
But I know I don't want
to wind up like that.
And if there's anything I can do
in my power to prevent
that from happening,
I should probably pursue that and do that.
I don't have the stable
life of a loving wife
and children that looked out for you.
I mean, hell one of them
gave him his kidney.
My brother, he was the
perfect match, but I don't,
I don't want to be alone
because I can see myself.
If I lived that similar
life to my father, in terms
of his physical health, I will
not have someone be willing
to play private duty nurse
for a decade like my mom did,
I'll be a vegetable in a nursing home.
Like I was in 2010, the only patient,
they were under 70 years old.
And it, that will be my life
if I continue to waste away
in terms of a purpose.
And that's what you were
talking about in the touchdown.
You know, the last video
I still haven't found
what I'm looking for in
terms of a goal to life.
And I sure hope that hits me someday soon.
- [Interviewer] Did you feel
like you've lived the life
that you wanted to?
- I have lived the best
life based on the cards
that I've been dealt,
but I stacked that deck in a bad way.
I'm aware of the impediments
to my ideal self.
But, I created it, you know,
rather than stacking the deck with,
you know, wild cards, I was all, you know,
like twos or seven, two if
you're going to play poker.
So I just, it's very
empowering cause I can see it.
It's just that right motivation.
And I must clean house
physically, mentally,
every at capacity.
Take a good deep look
at those I'm closest to
and make sure that it is a circle
of people that I see
there for the long haul,
because I know there are some
that are not, some that are.
A friend of mine in New York
city, not the one I talked
about last time, but
another friend in New York,
his favorite quote is
that people are here or people come
into your life for a season,
a reason, or a lifetime.
And I got to stop hanging out
with those areas here just
for the reason,
they're the easiest ones to come across.
But they're usually
the ones that are most,
most able to stop you from
that progress in life.
The season ones, hey,
that means that they're
around for a good little chunk
of time and for a good, solid reason.
And that's a good thing,
but I need to find those lifetime ones
and allow myself that
standard that I do put
on myself and not allow myself
to be coerced so easily.
So agreeing to give.
What California has taught me
is that yeah, like I said, just
before we started recording,
it seems like the California state model
or LA's or something is
that what's in it for me?
And I hate that.
Where's the goodness,
kindness, out of compassion?
Just out of your heart
from doing something.
- [Interviewer] To me, all these topics
that you just spoken about,
they all boil down to love.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's, you
wipe away all of this BS,
all this crap
and it, you boil everything
down to its essence.
It's always about.
- I need love.
- [Interviewer] The real
unconditional accepting love,
whether it's career we're talking about,
whether it's relationships,
whether it's about, yeah.
- It doesn't necessarily be intimate,
physical sexual relationship
because you can have that type
of connection with platonic friends.
As long as you know there, you know.
- [Interviewer] No there's
many ways to be loving.
I'm not saying a romantic
relationship per saying.
I'm saying-
- Someone that's
on your team that has
your back unquestionably.
- [Interviewer] I have male friends.
I'm straight.
I have male friends that I know,
beyond a shadow of a doubt, love me.
And I love them.
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] And they
would do anything for me.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] and I
would do anything for them.
- Exactly and that's-
- [Interviewer] That's hard to find.
- That is hard to find.
And when you have lived
the life that I have,
it's almost like I'm making
that opportunities harder
to find because those that
engage in similar practices I do,
you know, they're just there
for the reason, not the
season, not the lifetime.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- I don't like that.
- [Interviewer] And that's a horrible way
to go through life,
thinking these are your friends.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] Because
they're far from it.
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] But they
kind of look like it.
So you let them in.
- You have to be.
And learn that not to be so gullible.
- [Interviewer] It's important
to know the difference
between a somebody who looks
like a friend and oh yeah,
something to do next weekend
or somebody who is truly a friend.
And very often a lot of people
don't know the difference.
- That's like Missouri.
Show me that you are, you know,
that person that you claim
to be in order for me to.
- [Interviewer] I don't
take that combative attitude
about it.
You just, you either
recognize it or you don't.
You don't need to,
I don't put anybody
through a proving practice.
- Exactly.
I hate it.
And I had someone even
basically spell that out to me.
That's how they operate.
And I'm thinking to myself, hey, hey, hey.
Out of that though, by just simply saying,
I need to see a worth,
not necessarily, you know,
x number of like, oh,
are you taking care of me five times?
That means you're a pal.
No, no, no, no.
It's not like that.
It's just a lot of it boils down
to how you see them interact with others.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Cause that's their true
self, whatever they show
to you is whatever, but analyze
how they work with others.
- [Interviewer] It's important.
- And that's what that is.
It's by showing.
It's like, do I see that same
type of compassion, concern
respect for all peoples?
I've had some that, you know,
you felt were all cool and everything.
And then they say the things
that make you cock your head
and turn like what the
F is wrong with you.
And so I have to be very mindful
of myself and remain
guarded like a poker player.
I mean, I don't have to
show my cards immediately
but you know, once I'm comfortable
and there is a thing,
don't get too comfortable
too early with anybody.
And that's where that,
when I was saying like, show
me whatever, like Missouri, no,
I don't want to be
Missouri, but I want to be.
- [Interviewer] It's important
to go through life without too much fear
of who's screwing me over.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And also
not to be too gullible.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's a-
- [Interviewer] A lot of the
universal law of physics,
that balance is always there.
- And there's part of
the flaws that I can see
in myself is that I am too
gullible, too trusting.
That's why I am a few blocks
from Skid Row, where I live.
- [Interviewer] I would tend to be,
put myself in that same category.
I'm much more trusting than I could,
that most than most people.
- Doing what you do,
I'm sure allowed you that
opportunity to grow more
than what you were before
because you were seeing everyone's story.
Everyone's thing.
That's what motivates you.
- [Interviewer] Well, I've
always been super curious.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Interviewer] So
that's been since birth.
So, that leads me down
to this kind of project.
- Right.
And that's really awesome.
I don't know your star sign,
with or whatever your gastrological thing,
but I mean, I'm a Pisces.
- [Interviewer] I don't
buy this astrology stuff,
but I'm an Aquaries.
- Oh well,
I mean, it's not like,
you know, the horoscope,
like where you like look
at it in the newspaper,
like today you're going to
win $5,000, but lose $4,999
of it.
So ha no, no, but I feel that
there is some sort of weight,
but a planet's gravitational pull.
I mean like look at Mars and the moon
has enough gravitational
pull to do the tides.
It's not out of the realm
of possibility to me
that having Neptune or, you know,
Jupiter come into things
that are closer to us.
Even though they're hundreds
of millions of miles
away, I can accept it.
There might be some sort of pull
that happens because I can
feel the Pisces peoples
that I know do traits
in myself that are more
pronounced than other people
where it's like some don't
have that compassionate willing
to help out others genuine honest.
And, I forgot where I was going, sorry.
- [Interviewer] It's okay.
- That's the benefit of talking too much.
- [Interviewer] No, it's a great talk.
This is wonderful.
- [Man 1] Oh thank you.
- [Interviewer] No, we'll cut it off here.
Thank you so much you're
interesting as can be
as always.
- [Man 1] Oh thank you much.
- [Interviewer] I love talking with you.
- [Man 1] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Alright.
- [Man 1] Ciao, thank you.